- It's not really about the accolades,
that those will come,
but the work, when you feel like you
you know that feelin'
- Yes.
- When you feel like, I nailed that.
I need to have realness around me
to kind of break through all the
smoke and mirrors, if you will.
If I want to go visit Thailand, I'm going.
You know what I mean?
And eat some crazy food that
you would never eat, maybe.
Well, I want to try it.
- She's a rapper, singer,
actress and talk show host.
She gained mainstream success
for her performance in the film Chicago.
She's long been considered
one of hip hop's pioneer feminists.
She's Queen Latifah, and here's my take
on her top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're
watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well
and when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick with you, as well.
Enjoy.
(airplane engine soaring)
(cheerful orchestra melody)
- You've won a Grammy,
you've got nominations for an Oscar,
you won a SAG award,
you won a Golden Globe.
You've done so much.
How do you keep going?
What inspires you?
- Honestly, I pray always
to stay open, you know?
If you are always learn something new,
then you can be inspired.
But I don't just kind of
sit and look at the past,
like I did this.
Until people like you remind
me of a lot of that stuff
I don't really think
about it in the same way
because I see the new
things on the horizon
and I don't feel like I have to do
the same thing over and over.
I think if you're a creative person
then you kind of just
have to follow your vibe.
If an opportunity is there
for something interesting
that kind of sparks that thing in you,
then you go for it.
And I'm just kind of
never one of those people
who felt like I couldn't do it.
I've got the right people around me
that I believe to do
anything I put my mind to.
- Well you do
- If God wants it for me.
- You kind of mastered
everything that you've done.
- I don't master it all but
I persevere through it all
and it gives me a chance
to find the next thing to work on.
So I'm a fighter.
I know how to take 'em as
much as I can give 'em.
I been a business woman all these years.
I get a lot of joy, like
when we first managed
Naughty by Nature, just
taking them from A to Z,
getting them signed,
helping 'em create their record,
helping 'em create their
name, their image, all that
and watching them put out a hit record
that became platinum.
There's a good feeling in that
because you know you had something to do
with helping someone else
become a super success.
And now they have opportunity,
their family is good,
they have a career they can run with,
that feels good.
Just like playing some
role that's super difficult
or so challenging in some way
where you got to go to
some deep, dark place
within yourself,
or you got to give yourself therapy
to get through your own mess
so you can play this thing,
and then you see it on screen
and you see that it worked.
That feeling is amazing.
It's not really about the
accolades that, those will come,
but the work, when you feel like
you know that feeling
- Yes.
- When you feel like, I nailed that.
And you go to sleep that
night feeling like, "Wow!"
- 'Cause you are in the forefront, honey.
(chuckles)
- Well, I don't know.
I don't know what kind of leader I am,
but I don't know I'm not
trying to be a leader.
I'm just trying to be me.
And if something that I
say helps someone else out
then that's fine, but to go out and say,
"Okay, I'm the role model
around these here parts
"and I'm the spokesperson for all women."
I'm not trying to do that
because we are individuals
and we all have minds of our owns
and things we want to say for ourselves
and I just say the things I
want to say, is what I say.
Not what other people want me to say.
I have real people around me.
I think that's the best way
to maintain your realness
is to have honest people around you
who actually care about you.
So there's a balance.
I think as creative
people, we can be sensitive
so there's a way (giggles)
to talk to us
but at the same time,
I think it's important
to really have an idea of where you are,
who you are
and not have just a bunch
of yes-men around you,
unless that's your thing.
Maybe that works for some people,
but that doesn't really work for me.
I need to have
realness around me to kind
of break through all the
smoke and mirrors, if you will.
And we create a lot here.
We build this construct around us here,
so we need to have real people
to kind of let us know, keep us grounded.
Keep me grounded, for sure.
I've always been the kind to
switch for different things.
I'm interested in different things, too.
So I have to have the freedom
to step into those worlds
and not feel like, oh I got to stay here,
keep this certain persona,
be this person, no.
If I want to go visit Thailand, I'm going.
You know what I mean?
And eat some crazy food
that would never eat, maybe.
Well, I want to try it.
You know what I mean?
So that's just who I am.
So I think being okay
with that has allowed me
to not be afraid to go into
different things and places
and try different things
and kind of move my own personal needle
forward a little bit.
- [Interviewer] Has
there never been a point
where you have felt frustration,
sort of, in Hollywood?
I'm sure maybe it was
earlier in your career.
- Absolutely,
absolutely, but you know what?
You run into stupid people
everywhere, unfortunately.
Doesn't matter if it's the cab driver
who doesn't want to stop for you
or go past 110th Street
or if it's some executive
who someone managed to
become in a position of power
to greenlight movies who has no clue.
I mean, some things are just timing
and determination and perseverance.
If you don't have a sense
of your feet on the ground,
if you're not level-headed to some degree,
you could really lose it.
'Cause you literally have
all these people telling you
how incredible you are,
and if you don't have a sense
of yeah, but, I still have
to take out the garbage.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I still got to walk my
dog and poop up scoop,
do you know what I'm saying?
Scoop up poop.
If you don't keep your head,
then you could kind of
get a little souped up,
a little conceited and lose your edge.
Or some people take themselves
too seriously after that.
They feel they have to
do every incredible,
I did Scary Movie 2
after that.
- [Interviewer] I loved that.
- It was just because the kids loved it
and I'm like, I asked
one of my friend's kids,
"Did you like Scary Movie?"
And he was like, "Yeah."
I'm like, "Do you think I
should do Scary Movie 2?"
He was like, "Yeah."
Well I trust a nine-year-old, why?
Because I don't owe them money,
they don't owe me money,
they're not gettin' a cut off of it.
They just, it's just real.
So I did it, just for fun,
and then did more critical kind of things
but I mix it up.
What I don't think we should do
is limit ourselves in
any way, shape or form
in terms of what we
think we're capable of.
And I think that's been
part of the problem.
We're relegated into
these particular fields
and who says that you
can only do those things?
Unless it's something
physically preventing you
from doing it,
in which case, leave it alone.
But other than that,
go for it, like go for it.
But just be prepared for what
you are going to deal with those things.
And when you find people
you can connect to,
who will support you,
whether they're male or female,
those are the people you
need to keep in your life,
because my partner, Shakim,
has respected my brain
from the very beginning.
Not just my get-down,
not just my rap skills
or not just how cool I am,
but really, he respected
my mind from the beginning.
And so, he and I can get
together intellectually
and come up with something,
and then we talk shit to each other
and like, "Yo, I betcha we can.
"We can do that.
"You can't do that.
"Yes we, well that's how we,"
and then, we bang about
how we can make it happen.
But if he didn't respect me,
then it wouldn't even go there.
If I didn't respect him,
then it wouldn't go there.
So, I don't think we always
have to live on an island,
not with guys or not with women.
I think we just need
to connect with people
who get what we trying to go,
we moving in the same direction.
And the rest, those are the ones,
the haters or those who
tell you, "You can't do it,"
the negative ones or the hanger's-on,
that's the dead weight you got to cut.
I've had a guy who drove
me in his limousine,
tell me his 12-year-old
daughter has a beautiful voice
and she was afraid to
sing and she would cry
because her classmates would tease her
and tell her she's never going to make it,
she can't do this, and by looking at me,
she started singing again.
And she's like, "If Queen
Latifah can do it, I can do it,"
because she looked more like me
and because she had a
Queen Latifah to look at
and inspire her to stay on her path,
follow her dreams.
So, I think it's been a great thing.
I feel good about how I've been able
to impact people's lives.
We just follow the moves, right?
♫ I've had a little bit too much
♫ Much oh oh oh ♫
- Give us some encouragement here!
(audience cheering and applauding)
(audience clapping rhythmically)
♫ Can't find my drink or man
♫ Where are my keys
♫ I lost my phone
♫ What's goin' on
- Okay, that's not too bad to do, right?
Uh oh.
(dance partner squeals)
Oh boy.
Oh yeah, I like this part.
I kind of get to chill out.
(audience cheering and
clapping rhythmically)
♫ Just dance
♫ Going to be okay
♫ Da da doo doot-n
- Ah, this is fun!
- Oh get it, give it to her!
(dance partner giggling)
- My boobies are falling out!
(both laughing)
- Let 'em out,
they're my favorite body parts.
(both giggling)
♫ Just dance ♫
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
FOCUS WSU asked me to.
Also, if you want to nominate someone
for the next top 10 video,
please check the description
for a link to a video where
you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video.
What was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shoutout Kat Harvey.
Kat, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word,
and the fun interview we did
together on your channel.
It was a blast, I really
appreciate your support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
- Today, we have a special guest
who I admire and love.
This guy has a huge heart.
When you think of him,
I think of inspiration
and definitely the money
'cause he's a boss, of course,
and he's helping changing
lives all over the world.
Just pouring into a lot of people.
His videos on YouTube is
how I actually found him,
so of course, I had to have him on today.
So without further adieu,
please welcome the mogul himself,
Mister Evan Carmichael.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see you soon.
(jet engine soaring)
- Once you know what your dream is,
setting those goals to
accomplish that dream.
It will require a sacrifice,
it will require work,
it will require maybe sleepless nights,
but your passion for what your dream is
has to be that strong that you're willing
to sacrifice all that to accomplish it.
Put good people around you
that can help you get to
where you're trying to go,
move you in the right direction.
Don't get caught up in
a crazy relationship
in college unless you went
to college to get married,
which some do.
In that case, find a good man
and do it quick (chuckles)
before somebody else does.
Other than that, stay
focused on your education.
Focus in important,
don't get caught up going here
and there and everywhere.
Just keep your eyes on the prize,
keep God in your life and you'll be there.